everything has to have a story so the  more you can figure out a way to get  stories to bring out the best in you  there's nothing wrong with some of the  stuff that moves you if you like exotics  great because there's a story if you  like cards if you like jewelry if you  like stamps if you like  an artwork a painting a  a a certain thing that reminds you of  your parents your heritage your blood  something that gets you emotional you  have to try to figure out to go from  here out  if you go from out here it's fake yeah  if you go from here out  it's going to get the most out of you  versus you saying i like what he's doing  i like what she's doing i want to be  like him i want to be like this start  from here let other people inspire you  yeah but always start for me it always  gives you better results